i like listen to like npr bbc new york
times like
all one story like why do they even have
different like publications if they're
gonna have one narrative
they should just making one channel like
north korea so much easier for people to
follow
and i think it just it just reminds me
of like the
the animal farm how it all began and the
beginning just like don't think oh it's
not a big deal it doesn't affect my life
right now
and then suddenly like you start keeping
being purged
and being executed and we are not in
this state where like we are executed
but like you literally get cancer
and you don't like lose platform on
social media like you lose your voice
and that is almost like similar
execution for like activists like
me like if i lose my people like my
influence then i cannot let them know
the truth
right how do i ever fight in this system
what do you make of the senate where
like just where we're at in america
forgetting the election just generally
like you know you mentioned some some of
the negative things that have happened
to you
but obviously something truly incredible
things have happened to you
at the same time so
yeah i've been also starting my youtube
channel and like
i was doing live and talk about how pure
socialism can be
so poisonous can never work and of
course i'm sure you know that
a youtube demonetized or our videos
right
and i was wondering like how like
any idea should be up for debate i
thought that's what
freedom meant and here we have this like
code of like where we have to i mean i
went to colombia in new york
you can and how it felt like for me
going through another four years of
oppression there
like they talk about pressure by member
there's another oppression that they
cannot see
and i think that's why i just don't know
like how even to fight i feel like
i came to america like four or five
years ago
and like were you guys always like it's
crazy like how these
we weren't i promise you we weren't
always this crazy but we need people
like you to
to help us find the way again i mean
that's why i wanted to have you on the
show because you've
you've lived through this stuff you've
lived through it and then when i saw the
video and you're
and you're somehow referencing my book
and i'm going this this is crazy i mean
you you've lived through it i'm talking
about this stuff at the idea level
although i fear
that most of the things that i was
worried about in the book are starting
to become true
yeah it's uh i mean until i didn't get
robbed and seeing people
how they are like you know this is
something you would read like on the
like conspiracy theory like news sites
these people were standing on the
michigan avenue in chicago like 2
2 p.m like during the day near the macy
and police cars were nearby
and these people see me being punched
and calling me racist because they only
see
only thing they could see was a color in
their eyes the other
black i was like asian that's all
and that's like when i thought like oh
this is like not it's not like i'm
trying to online people
this is a complete gun madness and i
don't even know how to go back to the
like
the middle zone where some saniki like
horse
yeah you sort of referenced this a
little while ago but
the idea that if you talk about these
things
freedom free speech all of the things
that you've just described here
that if you talk about them you're
suddenly thought of as like
right wing that this is now a right wing
thing
how has that affected your ability to to
do
your advocacy and and build bridges and
things like that
yes the things are so hard like how they
are so easy to call in names now
right this they're so busy like making
few new names for people and then
holding them into this little box and
it's been very challenging like actually
doing
this like all my friends were like you
are fighting for norskin people you
cannot doing this you cannot talk about
any of these problems
just stick with north korea but like in
order to north korea and
serve those i need to like serve china
first the problem of north korea the
root is chinese region like communist
party
it's not kim jong can never survive in
one day without
being so i mean how do i like fight this
massive fight without like letting
people know what's happening and what
china is doing to the humanity
and then as soon as i of course
criticize mainstream media for not like
highlighting this issue then you know
i'm becoming a right extreme
like yeah crazy person what do you think
about our media here so as someone that
grew up with
as you said one channel uh
our media our mainstream media kind of
feels like one channel
at a certain level i mean it is one
channel it's uh
i i just like i mean i like listen to
like npr bbc new york times like
all one story like why do they even have
different like publications if they're
gonna have one narrative
they should just make one channel like
north korea so much easier for people to
follow
and i think it just it just reminds me
of like the
the animal farm how it all began and the
beginning just like don't think oh it's
not a big deal it doesn't affect my life
right now
and then suddenly like you start keeping
being purged
and being executed and we are not in
this state where like we are executed
but like you literally get cancer
and you don't like lose platform on
social media like you lose your voice
and that is almost like similar
execution for like activists like me
like if i lose
my people like my influence then i
cannot let them know the truth
right how do i ever fight in this system
and like
my like fight is depending on the tech
companies their decision on me
like one day like oh i can let her be
heard and i can be heard but if they
decide i cannot be heard i cannot be
heard
it's not up to me anymore and that's
like what just fits in my everything
like
how am i despite yeah you know it's
interesting when people
ask me what i love most about doing this
show it's this right now because
think about like our lives are so
different came from such different
places
and the things that you care about are
the exact things
that i care about like it's actually
incredible how these
sort of eternal ideas just end up
bringing us together
yeah i mean i think it's it's freedom is
something that we can
i think that's what i'm so like scared
for going to colombia is like they don't
understand like like people in your bone
with like two arms you never know what
it feels like to live without two arms
and these people like colombia keep like
wondering about what would it be like
without like freedom
right they have no clue what it's gonna
be without it and they
keep trying to experiment this new idea
and there's like knowledge i mean i know
what it feels like living without these
like rights and freedom and why are
trying to keep abandon them
they our ancestors fall for our freedom
of speech
and like they blood their blood for it
freedom is not free there was a price
they paid for
and now because they got it for free
they just don't want to see what it
feels like without two arms
and it's not that great like it's your
life is gonna be so miserable
and i think that's like what shocks me
horrifies me how
ignorant and this evil this like
ignorant idea is can you also talk a
little bit about how it's not just
like the the bad actors that spread
these ideas but
how the average person just kind of
gives up
like what you saw in north korea when
you were a kid and then china when you
were a little bit older about how the
average person
just sort of checks out because that
seems to be the stage that we're in
right now
here so yeah i was thinking like
so in north korea if you commit a crime
it doesn't end with you
like it attracts to three generations of
your family
sometimes a generation which means like
you
you're in loads of cousins cousins like
that so one like the factory escapes
with highlight
however he's like i mean 30 000 people
got purged for that and like usually
it's three generations so your grandpa
your children all of it
and like and in america now if it's like
if i say something that was maybe
completely aware 30 years ago it gets
back to me
and i don't know what's going to get
back to me 30 years down the road
and how it's gonna affect my son like
people talking about something that
happened in the like time in the
ancestral age and they have to be
responsible for that
about the slavery thing that is like
exactly reminds me of that like
because some my ancestors did so many
many lifetime ago
how does it affect me how does it make
me feel geared right
and these are complete ideas from north
korea i don't know where this idea is
coming from like
we are making people so guilty and shame
them
and that's what north korea is all about
shaming people and make them feel guilty
and punish them
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell